in this video I want to talk a little
bit about DNA packaging which is
basically how DNA is packed in
eukaryotes so I'm going to use human
specifically as an example the human
genome is about 3 billion base pairs
long
so each chromosome has millions of base
pairs now each bit each of these base
pairs is like nanometers short like it's
not very long but if you think about
millions or even billions of them if you
took our entire genome actually recently
read this this paper that said that if
you stretch out the entire human genome
you would have and like it would be long
enough to go from here to the Sun and
back 300 times
that's insane so it's extremely wrong ok
think about that all this stuff is
packed in our tiny cells we have
trillions of cells hundreds 100 trillion
cells or so that's a lot of cells now
these these DNA strands right and if
they were just like you know just long
strings just chillin in our cells that
would take up a lot of space so instead
of having them just hanging out as
strings with what's going on is they're
packed and into a little compact sort of
well I'll get to it in just a second so
something to keep in mind is a human DNA
of course is linear so it would be
really really long so with this DNA take
up a bunch of space in a cell the answer
is of course so we must solve that
problem and that is done by packaging
the DNA ok now what do we want to think
about what we're going to think about is
that this pink line that I've drawn here
is DNA so this DNA is wound around these
little brown circles that I've drawn
here these brown circles what we call
histones now we'll talk more about
histones later but histones are little
proteins that basically
their purposes is to help pack DNA so
the DNA is wound around these histones
and continually wound in one of the
background and as it's wound these
little they look like beads on a string
if you've ever back in elementary school
had a little string and maybe in arts
and crafts you put beads on the string
and then you get made of necklace or
something kind of what's going on here
looks like beads on a string and
eventually they're packed into these
little groups of eight and that little
group of eight is called a nucleosome so
basically once you have a group of eight
histones they form in this little
complex and that's called a nucleosome
and it's got a package and package and
package and package and eventually
eventually we get these little
structures and you probably already
familiar with these these are called
chromosomes okay so long strings of DNA
are packaged and coiled around these
these proteins and eventually they're
packaged in package a package more
condensed and condensing and thence more
and more and more and more until we
eventually make these chromosomes now
why am I talking about this why is is
important at all this is important
because in order for replication and for
transcription to occur of this DNA this
DNA can't be wound around these around
these histones it can't be bound like it
I'll condense like this and needs to be
out and accessible for certain enzymes
so we will need to unpack DNA in order
to do to have DNA replication occur as
well as transcription which is actually
something we'll talk about specifically
later one thing I do want to hint at is
that if DNA is charged right it has a
negative charge
what kind of charge would you expect the
histones to have while opposite charges
attract right they should have positive
charges now if there are amino acids to
me if histones are proteins and proteins
are made up of amino acids what type of
amino acid would you expect it sort of
exists on the surface of histone
especially the portions in which are
interacting with a DNA it would expect
them to be basic amino acids things that
have the positive charge so things like
histidine arginine and lysine matter of
fact histones have lots of lysine
residues so lysine residues that have
that positive charge and we'll talk more
about that later I hope that video was
helpful to sort of get an idea of what's
going on and hope it kind of blew your
mind a little bit I am a tutor if you
live in Southern California feel free to
contact me via email i'm luke university
at gmail.com see the description below
for more details thank you for watching